madame a la pone a ministro ante un
parlamento dividido la nueva primera
ministra de francia elizabeth bone se
subió al atril para presentar la hoja de
ruta política del gobierno para los
próximos años
ante estos retos el desorden y la
inestabilidad no son una opción puede
que no estemos de acuerdo en las
soluciones pero todos somos conscientes
de la necesidad de importancia de actuar
uruguay obtenido en inputs con fax en
esa unidad puede ser difícil de
conseguir tras perder escaños en las
recientes elecciones el partido de
manuel mccone se encuentra sin opciones
y sin mayoría por lo tanto es probable
que la aprobación de su programa
político se reduzca a coaliciones
proyecto por proyecto sin embargo bones
siguió adelante la principal prioridad
del gobierno es hacer frente a la crisis
del coste de vida
confirmando los planes de aumento de las
pensiones y de la limitación de la
subida de los alquileres y de los
precios de los servicios públicos
otro de los objetivos claves de mccrone
se reiteró en el pleno de la asamblea
nacional el impopular aumento de la edad
de jubilación de los 62 a los 64 años
nuestro modelo social es una paradoja es
uno de los más generosos y a la vez uno
de los que menos años trabaja nuestro
sistema de pensiones es una excepción si
se mira a nuestros vecinos europeos
contiene un camino que recorrer si
quiere ganarse a otros diputados para la
agenda del gobierno con un control tan
frágil del poder el gobierno rompió con
su precedente de 30 años al decidir no
celebrar una votación de confianza tras
el discurso los políticos de la
coalición opositora han y pest poco
impresionados presentaron una moción de
censura que se votará en los próximos
días pero salvo sorpresas importantes
bolt debería superar la mayoría absoluta
necesaria después de que los
conservadores republicanos y la otra
derecha dijeran que no apoyaran la
moción